and now on to the dye the deep dive into
the most popular wildest conspiracy
surrounding the Denver International
Airport yeah this room February 27th so
it's not that not that long ago friday
marks the airport's 25th birthday so a
bunch of stories popped up specifically
because it was the anniversary they were
doing construction and everyone loves to
talk about the conspiracies at the
Denver Airport so I'll read a little bit
of this they say or they foolish rumor
has taken one step too far or is there
some truth to the conspiracies of the
Denver International Airport it depends
on how far you're willing to let your
imagination run wild for you perhaps the
truth is what you perceive as reality or
maybe it's just what you want to believe
or maybe it's basically anything that is
yet to be disproved when examined with
even this just a sliver of truth the
proof of these conspiracies seems pretty
feeble and far-flung but Alex Renteria a
spokesman with the airport said it's
clear that it is that that isn't
stopping the hardcore conspiracy
theorists and that's just fine by DIA
which is celebrating its 25th birthday
Friday it's not as exciting as everybody
wants to be but I think that's why we
love it so much let's get excitement
around our Airport and that's okay if
people think we're weird and have the
Illuminati and that aliens land their
spaceships here that's fine with us keep
thinking it and we'll keep trying to
prove you wrong but we're not afraid to
embrace those conspiracies it's a
publicity stunt I think so I think so
yeah I think so look at this they say it
only gets more bizarre when you learn
about the conspiracies of who calls
these tunnels home lizard people
lizard people I believe that one is so
wild to me Renteria said I don't know
I'm wondering if someone fueled it
somewhat somebody just decided that that
was the case and they were like now
there's lizard people here that's
exactly how that happens
Denver 7 previously reported that the
lizard people are supposedly controlling
the airport and can change forms as they
work to rule the world
Renteria said dia is taking this one in
stride in our marketing campaign in the
Great Hall there is a reference to
lizard people in the tunnels
she said we know that rumor is alive and
well and didn't Billy Corgan say that he
witnessed someone like D shed their skin
and a lizard person popped up that was a
super chat oh it was I don't know no no
I've actually heard that before that
super chat so it wasn't like that's
where I the only place I heard that the
fact that I heard it again I was like
aha
someone else is saying that hmm watching
someone turning well you know what man
anything's possible yeah scent like even
if it was a point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero I couldn't make
0.1% chance that's still it could happen
I guess I just don't think they're
lizard people I encourage anybody who
does believe in it keep believing she
said who knows maybe someday we will see
a lizard person
if there are no lizard people are there
at least aliens there are no aliens she
said this isn't a place where aliens can
land their ship I guess that's what we
call them no unfortunately I feel like
that would be against FAA regulations
for anything to land beside aircraft and
how about the Illuminati the world's
elites will members bunker the tunnels
during apocalypse
Renteria said this is also untrue though
she jokingly wished there was some truth
to it because she feels confident that
she'd be able to nab a spot in the
bunker if the world was indeed coming to
an end I feel like the Illuminati
would like a nicer place don't get me
wrong I love our tunnels but I'm just
thinking that with all this money if
they're the world's elite they'd want a
nice place some wallpaper some marble
floors
well what's at the end of the tunnel
that's right or in the sieve ages the
tunnels but like we gotta go down to the
end then you got the underground castle
that's right well the the tunnel to the
underworld where though those are people
excuse me excuse me the underworld camp
right of course she confirmed that no
airport employees have ever reported any
strange sightings and tunnels though
there are some drawings that could
possibly depict aliens
really wait in the tunnels don't plan on
sniffing around on your own to find the
tunnel or lizard people dia is after all
an airport and security is very tight
I'm sure people are very curious and
want to walk into doors that are
unmarked or say dangerous when there's
really just like a furnace back there
the public is not allowed in the tunnels
due to safety hazards conspiracy
theorists may argue this is just another
move to cover up the secrets of dia and
of course it is public spaces are public
for a reason and we keep the public out
of certain spaces for their safety and
for the safety of others Frontera said
as we just saw there's somebody welding
nearby I mean this is a total operation
so it'd be really hard to have
passengers just hanging out down here
she compared to the
sewage systems the public simply isn't
allowed down here there's one exception
traveler travelers would be welcome to
tunnels if a tornado was threatening
their safety
there is one conspiracy the tunnels she
said she can take seriously there's an
elusive soda machine that I've heard
about that is 25 cents for a soda who
knows I've never found it that's the
real conservatives okay okay okay so
that's their official name but let's uh
let's see this is a photo and for those
are listening let me describe it it is a
Nazi I guess and he has a sword and a
machine gun and a machine and and some
yes I'm kind of machine gun with a
bayonet on it and he is stabbing a dove
it appears there's some weeping people
surrounding him with like dead babies
and people along on the ground and it's
a quite quite a horrifying picture you
know I didn't notice this before uh
you're about to move to the next one
right oh yeah look at his gloves notice
the gloves we were talking about the
other gloves in the other picture yeah I
didn't notice that those were the same
clothes I mean the different color
oh are they yeah okay so interesting so
you see this guy right this like a
rainbow and then it turns to I don't
know what does it turn into out of smoke
or something yeah it's like a smudger it
comes open so body there to clarify this
is a mural at the Denver International
Airport we're going to show you a bit
more of the art so the next the next one
we have is the continuation of it right
right so there's the rainbow coming over
to this side and then this one it says
you know a bunch of like I guess it says
peace and various languages and you can
see all of these different people races
and ethnicities of the world coming
together where there is what appears to
be my guess is it fair to say it's like
an Aryan kid blonde hair blue-eyed kid
with an iron fist yeah I don't know a
hammer and it looks like he's destroying
a sword I would I guess it I think it's
the sword the guy had because look
there's the the the the Nazi dude I
guess he's dead he's dead and they're
the birds they're alive and well and
this dude looks like he's destroying a
hammer there's an anvil it kind of looks
like he's made of stone looks like look
at his right arm it's like broken like
stone would break even though even the
gun is broken
oh this guy you're right you're right
yeah and his leg oh yes rocks falling
apart interesting I mean it looks like
somebody was trying to make an all the
people of the world coming together for
world peace thing and they're like
destroying
it I don't really funky look in Annville
- yeah it is weird it's like everything
about I'm assuming it's an anvil but so
I so here's another photo there's
another one that gets people going like
oh the Freemason symbol Denver
International Airport dedication
capstone Wellington a web mayor and then
it says you know March 19th 1984
New World Airport Commission there it is
that's the proof everyone says that's
proof of the New World Order new world
Newport New World Airport so I think I
might have so here's here's a bunch of
the other photos - this is from out
there Colorado what's up with the creepy
apocalyptic paintings in Denver
International Airport this one's got
like what is that a penguin in a glass
case so that's the other picture thank
you penguin yeah nature pictures that a
blue whale humpback whale yeah there's
like turtles and there's like four the
world with forces burning and then
there's the weird like look at this the
airport itself those are the terminals
why is it I have no freaking clue
birds are up it looks great what does it
made of it's like a tent
what I dig it I dig it a lot actually it
was really cool I mean yeah sure it's
like that it's really heavy-duty is it
soft fabric it is like like reinforced
fabric yeah I mean they built that in 94
and it's still like going strong yeah
cool huh well they're not there's a
here's a kid who's got a squirrel but
he's sad for some reason I'll tell you
what if I this were I'd be happy oh
there's a dead person okay that's why
you say that I get it's it's Hansel and
there's Gretel look oh then what is this
everyone's rushing oh it's another one
there's like a weird plant they're all
like I mean it's just weird art you know
what I mean it's like here's that guy
stabbing the bird again yeah yeah I made
that I made this joke where where
someone someone in the airport was like
we need some art and anybody know any
artists and someone's like oh oh oh I
know I know an artist and they like
calls up his his like second cousin
who's like desperate for work he's like
hey I got the perfect opportunity for
you bring all those those great murals
you bought about or that you did about
world peace well yeah they're perfect
for us
look at this one blue mustang known
colloquially as blue cypher
oh that's my future mayor this is
Lucifer so this story is from the Denver
Post and they're talking about how
they've capitalized on it like we've
heard from that woman already they're
putting these you know conspiracy signs
under construction or underground
tunnels and they're I love it there's
girl feeding into it but what what's
with all the creepy art only now that I
moved away does this seem super super
weird because I lived there my whole
life and you were like God's normal
there's a giant demon worse yeah I
wonder if that demon horse likes soy
baby you know I think it's simple man
the person the person who was running
the show was into stupid like creepy art
definitely was I shouldn't say stupid I
mean it's like they're into creepy art
you know it is what it is or their
clothes significant other was like oh
let me get my artwork on there it's my
only chance I keep coming back to I
truly believe that's the case look at
this picture there's the blue surfer
firing lasers from his eyes are we
creating the world's greatest airport or
preparing for the end of the world you
see what you don't realize is they're
leaning into it to discredit anyone so
now if anyone's like oh I heard there's
a conspiracy oh it was an ad campaign
yeah one of my favorite pseudo
conspiracy kind of ideas was that men in
black the movie mm-hmm was purposefully
does not made so that if anyone ever
said the men in black are really but you
mean that movie but the movie the men in
black is based on like this idea that
government agents come and they erase
your memory and stuff like that it was
like obvious but then you know I was
reading a bunch of forums and it was
funny they're like now if anyone ever
says they actually saw the men in black
they're gonna be like you're just
talking about a movie you're crazy what
the men in black are real yeah you know
what do you know about it well nothing
much no I'll tell you I've been flashed
men in black are real but people were
talking aliens like there's actually men
in wearing black sure yeah they're real
no like they're gonna exactly fair
enough damn black suits that's exactly
it with Sri neuralyzer
so no not that part oh no what'll happen
is like you'll be a witness of something
or something and then all of a sudden
some government guys will show up and
last you questions and they'll leave
then people Beck I don't know where they
were from you know they were saying all
this stuff and they're with the
government and thing
like dance like yeah you know the stuff
this stuff happens like what do you
expect Yeah right so you know well this
is the Denver Airport I don't know what
else to tell you it's a creepy place but
I really doubt there's a sub-basement
full of aliens or lizard people thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you